previously on TV sentence what does God
need with a starship
[Music]
my name is Kara zor-el freaking
narration man so we can pretty much add
the DC show narration to death and taxes
on our list of certain things now right
considering about 37% of this episode is
narration let's just kick it off with 37
cents shall we 24 years ago my planet
Krypton was in serious peril
I feel like Kirk could save us a lot of
backstory just by saying hey remember
that Superman guy yes samesies
my cousin kal-el was sent to a planet
called Earth for his own safety and
protection you may know his story may
may everyone knows this seriously this
along with Bruce Wayne's parents getting
shot needs to be retired from any future
iteration of these properties
immediately the story you don't know is
that I was sent to protect him because
when watching a celebrity biopic we'd
all much rather be watching a film about
said celebrities bodyguard because of
the Earth's Yellow Sun we'll have great
powers on this planet so the Kryptonians
have this technology know this much
about this earth place why are kara and
Cal and maybe a few eventual guest stars
the only ones that make the trip
wouldn't you think a species this
advanced would have had a planet
emergency escape system that saved more
than just the kids from this one family
I slept there for 24 years until somehow
I got here so we're just gonna yeah
through that but in that same time my
cousin kal-el had grown up and revealed
himself to your world as Superman who
always seemed to have an intense
backlight blocking me from actually
seeing him since he was too important
and well-respected to slum it on a
narrow verse TV show for now so she gets
raised by former acting iterations of
Superman and Supergirl I have to wonder
how much better these shows might be if
instead of prioritizing stunt casting
they decided to prioritize things like
oh I don't know talent after all earth
didn't need another hero someone to tell
that to the hero verse I need to make
sure miss grant doesn't end up next to
Bill O'Reilly again well it shouldn't be
a problem anymore I was wondering if
maybe you want to I don't know go see go
see a movie tonight
I'm I can't I have a date jeez show you
can't even wait five minutes before
introducing the first will they won't
they love triangle of unrequited sexual
tension can we get just one superhero
whose life isn't dominated by romantic
quandary
as a human petri-dish it's like standing
up in coats Cara is using her super ears
to hear cat in the elevator but when she
comes out she's completely alone so who
exactly was she talking to you in such a
specific and witty manner good morning
miss grants the only reason I bought
this building was because it had a
private elevator
supergirl where's product you want to
save the trip go sign me a hero kerah
the fact that one of the reasons ma'am
of Steel started to superhero is related
to other employees job security is
hilarious as if the superhero economy
has to keep booming so that people don't
lose their superhero related jobs it
would be like if the film industry
decided to revolve itself so much around
superhero movies that they had to keep
making them so the whole thing didn't
collapse what a strange world that would
be hey I'm the new guy I just realized
the hot person was talking to me so let
me address you like a human being now oh
my god you're Jimmy Olsen the
photographer from The Daily Planet
James Olsen why would she even call him
Jimmy in the first place
is she in the habit of throwing
nicknames at every single person she
meets do that yes
oh so the layouts are ready so earlier
why did you say wait a minute man you
could have just said they're right there
on that table beside you unless it was
just an excuse to introduce Supergirl to
mr. Olsen in which case also there are
multiple layouts on the desk how does
Cara know which one to grab I have a
conference in Geneva and I need to be on
a plane in two hours two hours why are
you even here National City looks to be
a decent sized metropolis city and most
airlines recommend you be at your gate
an hour before takeoff I don't care if
the airport is literally three blocks
away and you have a TSA PreCheck coming
out of your ass you should already be
heading that way having a crappy boss
and absolutely nothing to wear
this is what normal looks like does
normal also look like too full mobile
closets in the living room is this a
thing for most people also nothing to
wear I literally have two pairs of jeans
three t-shirts and a hoodie you have
about 50 full color coordinated outfits
hanging in your freakin living room why
not go with blue it is your color it's
the dialogue in the show a pimple on
picture day because that couldn't be
more on the news also in just the first
10 minutes of the show Supergirl has a
blind date a separate left triangle
lost her composure over one boy
friendzone the other one and prioritized
a wardrobe decision over her sisters
travel schedule good thing we are
falling into any old super girly
stereotypes too quickly so where are you
from originally like where was I born
and
after all these years in the Kryptonian
protection program she doesn't have a go
to fake answer for this question
National City Airlines flight 237 bound
for Geneva is experiencing some loss of
altitude I'm not sure which is more
convenient here at the exact plane that
Supergirl sister took is in peril or
that they not only had a television in
this chic national city bar but we're
also somehow playing the local news on
it now that's definitely the second one
but the two of them together combined to
form a sin to the power of five he asks
the super focused super girl with super
hearing good to see most of the
passengers secured there I mean good to
see some of the passengers wait a second
did not a single passenger put on their
oxygen mask the thing about Alex is
nightmare and not quite 20,000 feet
moment here is that it's super
convenient that she's the only one who
sees this now boarding Group a for
Geneva first class parents of small
children and anyone who needs to force
plot movements you are now free to board
you said it's Supergirl also if she has
the insane strength that would take to
turn an aircraft going hundreds of miles
per hour doesn't she also have the
strength to lift it above or slow it
down in midair and set it down make
healthy choices car up me healthy
choices I would take off 20 sins and
declare DC the winner of the comic book
wars of a mustachioed Tom Hanks walks
out of that plane right now this is a
nice nod to the co-creator of Supergirl
and all but does that mean Otto bender
is a real person in this universe does
that mean Supergirl comics are a thing
here too I love a shout out and
everything but stop messing with the
space-time continuum dammit this is what
I was talking about Alex I've always
felt the need to help people and tonight
I finally got that chance and there's
the teeny weeny matter that Alex
wouldn't can be alive if it wasn't for
Kara saving it what if people figure out
who you are I'm guessing it means they
can see through their eyeballs and
perhaps do basic facial comparative
analysis look I know it's been send a
million times and a million ways but
just one more time staying anonymous
when people see your full face is
impossible okay fine let's move on hey I
didn't want you I will say however that
you didn't think thanked me for saving
your life I don't have much to go on
image we're working off of his low res
is it though and only one because there
were like a hundred people with phones
on that plane and she was lit like
lin-manuel wanted to tell her story oh
my god you're a lesbian Oh Karl that's
why you're not into me this is this is
this is great nose Jesus even into
fifteen this dialogue is very uncouth
get away from the ledge you're gonna get
hurt what the hell Danvers you didn't
have to make the guy think you plunge to
your death to prove you could fly just
flow a little bit right in front of him
instead of making him think his little
crush just got a whole lot crushed
Supergirl is a super dick I'm not saving
this thing nope even though the show
debuted on CBS they decided on
fulfilling the CW superhero show mission
statement that CW showing as much skin
as possible without seeming creepy and
sometimes even more the new Cape is made
from the structured polymer composite
Wynn is an algorithm expert who believes
in aliens what exactly gives him the
ability to create bulletproof superhero
gear name is Hank Henshaw and I believe
you already know agent Danvers of course
Alex works for the Krypton villain
hunting organization because TV show she
doesn't need this you know what else she
didn't need to be shot out of the sky
with kryptonite darts and dragged into
here under duress sure you get to play a
nice little fake out on the audience but
there was no way her sister would have
allowed it to happen this way without
telling her first welcome to the de oh
the Department of extra-normal
operations do you mean like extra normal
as in things that aren't normal or extra
normal like things that are extremely
normal I really wanted to be the latter
basically the de Oh is a place where
everyone just staples things makes
coffee and runs the copier all day but
since I know it's not also it's located
in National City why up until recently
they had zero super heroes or villains
setting up shop here also Krypton
villain hunting organization is a much
better name when it crashed the alien
convicts
the worst criminals in the galaxy they
all escaped and Superman hasn't been
able to help stop any of these guys for
over a decade they've stayed hidden but
in the last year many have been emerging
conveniently corresponding to your
becoming Supergirl so that you can fight
them one by one in a series of what we
are going to call episodes you want to
help go back to getting someone's coffee
they're seriously not going to use cars
Helen the C universe deserves whatever
happens to it it's just kind of people
save one big coincidence doesn't it
Supergirl would be great of TV since I
know you don't want to hear this agent
Danvers but she's dangerous which is why
I'm just letting her walk out of here
if you can hear this okay not for now
sir
convenient magic alien walkie-talkie is
convenient sure she's wearing her super
shirt under her office clothes but are
we supposed to believe that her skirt
and boots are underneath those pants as
well and where's her Katy's it's stuffed
in the back of her shirt so that every
time she turns around it looks like
she's trying to smuggle something into
the office kill her
oh and yeomen clearly got his bad guy
boys from watching Clancy Brown in
Highlander you actually think you can
stop me she does have the exact same
powers as you do so probably yes I won't
be needing this anymore pursue the
hostile copy that
the deos goal is to stay truly secret
firing exploding missiles from a chopper
over the city seems a bit
counterproductive to me Cara it's me can
we talk I know you can see me because
hearing it wasn't proved enough what
does this even mean is this some sort of
end around on the I know you're in there
cliche
nice try show but we also can see right
through some things also I'm just gonna
talk about the superhero stuff at a loud
volume in a public apartment building
homework even though I derated you this
entire episode about giving away your
identity well it seems like the worst
possible way to do that Cara do it now
this was the endgame
to explode the ax with heat vision do
you know how many times during this
fight she could have just grabbed the
axe and flown it away to some private
island where she could have done this in
peace I'm gonna go with at least 15 also
they actually have things on earth that
can melt metal axes FYI and he committed
Hari Krishna night why exactly he was
handling his own in hand-to-hand combat
with Cara without the axe I was sent
here to protect my cousin
I loved my accent face I don't
understand why it's so difficult to
confirm the point no I'm so sorry
Miranda I actually did controls that
your incompetence do not interest me
where's my cave nothing I remember it
like it was yesterday
Christmas 1989 dad had just gotten fired
from the zipper factory mom was still
pulling in tricks to make ends meet
Daniel day-lewis win an Oscar for my
left foot and all I wanted was one of
those little Betsy wetsy dolls it's not
nests it's my family's coat of arms nerd
alert
I'm a girl and your boss and powerful
and rich and hot and doggone it people
like me help me obi-wan Kenobi you're my
only ow
if she's anything like her mother she
will be just as formidable and tween
[Applause]